[Musik]
und zugeschaltet aus berlin ist uns timo
grub allah fdp-bundesvorsitzender
mitglied des deutschen bundestags
direktkandidat im wahlkreis görnitz
grüße sie in die hauptstadt in den
reichstag
das reichstagsgebäude hair group aller
das war eine ziemlich lange nacht ich
nehme an wir haben nicht bis 2 uhr 30
ausgeharrt aber haben jetzt doch schon
alles aufgenommen worauf sich die bund
länder runde geeinigt hat wie wirkt das
auf sie man hat ja ein bisschen den
eindruck die geduld von vielen geht zu
ende
ja auch die geduld von uns
parlamentariern geht zu ende weil wieder
in einer kungelrunde die nacht vor allen
dingen durch werke entscheidung
getroffen hat die nicht mehr
nachvollziehbar sind wir müssen wirklich
hier mittlerweile konstatieren dass hier
einige der bundesregierung oder
vielleicht die bundeskanzlerin selbst
den verstand verloren hat dass man uns
von londons locker und hec die
bevölkerung keine perspektive hat also
wir sehen hier ein komplettversagen der
bundesregierung
herr kuba das ist natürlich jetzt
sozusagen ein scharfes wort
ich nehme mal an alle waren bei verstand
als sie sich das angeschaut haben was
die wissenschaftler dort präsentiert
haben
im bundeskanzleramt was die frage der
einbindung des parlaments angeht das
sind ja durchaus auch andere
oppositionsparteien die da einen haken
dran machen bis hin zur
koalitionsparteien das ist ja etwas was
im grunde genommen durch
regierungserklärung und beratungen im
parlament aufgelöst werden kann aber das
reicht ihnen nicht
und das reicht uns nicht wir fordern
natürlich auch die bundeskanzlerin
selbst aber wir am donnerstag stellung
zu beziehen in der regierungserklärung
sie ist für diese für dieses versagen
mitverantwortlich sie soll den bürgern
hier erklären was sie sich darunter
vorstellt wie das ostern aussehen soll
vor allem wie das weitergeführt werden
soll wir hangeln uns wie gesagt von
lockt anzulocken
wir müssen uns endlich mal um die 99 9
prozent der bevölkerung kümmern die
unter diesen maßnahmen leiden und das
ist eigentlich das was die bevölkerung
sieht wir erkennen immer mehr in den
familien die eltern verzweifelt was die
schuleröffnung angeht schulschließungen
man kann nach malaga in den urlaub
fliegen aber hierzulande darf man keinen
urlaub machen ist das wird dazu führen
dass die schließung der lokale und bzw
auch der geschäfte jetzt wieder über
ostern komplett beschlossen wurde das
natürlich einen run auf die supermärkte
vor und nach
was dann geschehen wird also es gibt
einfach keine konsistenz in den
entscheidungen und das muss die
bundeskanzlerin hier im parlament
erklären und das sollten wir hier auch
diskutieren
okay was kritisieren ist das sozusagen
die entscheidung für sie nicht stringent
wirken die die bundesregierung in dieser
pandemie gemeinsam mit der länder ebene
getroffen hat jetzt musste er kritisiert
natürlich auch sagen was würde er anders
machen sie sprechen die 99 prozent an
die leiden was würde die afg konkret
anders tun
ja ich beziehe mich darauf viele
wissenschaftliche meinung in dahin gehen
dass wir endlich von diesen incidents
irrsinnig mission
warum haben wir denn jetzt erhöhte
inzidenz sein weil wir natürlich
irgendwie die möglichkeit fast anfangen
zu testen ist auch ganz klar dass diese
infektionszahlen wieder steigen deswegen
sagen wir ganz klar wir müssen uns auf
die hospitalisierung zahlen in den
krankenhäusern konzentrieren die
krankenhäuser sind aktuell nicht
überlastet sie kommen mit dieser
situation klar
also hier muss die verhältnismäßigkeit
ins auge gebracht werden und natürlich
auch weiterhin die wohlhabenden gruppen
müssen geschützt werden das ist
geschieht meiner meinung nach immer noch
zu wenig also dass darauf müssen wir uns
konzentrieren welche bevölkerungsteile
sich wirklich mit diesem corona virus
infizieren bzw auch diese erkrankung
schwerwiegend durchleiden müssen darauf
müssen wir uns konzentrieren das sind
nicht die kinder sie persönlich also
sehr persönlicher und die afb würden
sich sozusagen von diesem incidents
pferd verabschieden und würden ihnen
durch andere werte ersetzen gut wir
haben das sozusagen jetzt ein jahr
durchexerziert das haben sie auch noch
gesagt wir haben deswegen so eine hohe
intelligenz bei so viel getestet wird
also den wird natürlich auch in der
wissenschaft widersprochen aber nehmen
wir das jetzt einfach mal so hin als ein
mögliches faktum heißt das dann sie sind
gegen testen
natürlich nicht gegen es testen und zwar
da wo es angebracht und da war natürlich
auch infektionsgeschehen klar
nachweisbar ist
das ist zum beispiel nicht in den
schulen wo keine hot spots existieren
also in weiterhin in krankenhäuser aber
auch ein altenheim da ist eine
testpflicht bzw 1 testen sicherlich
angebracht aber doch nicht im kompletten
leben was wir mittlerweile hier erleben
ist ein insider auch einen test wahnsinn
da fragt man sich ja wirklich wer
neuerdings wir wahrscheinlich wieder an
diesen testungen verdient welcher
cdu-abgeordnete dort mittlerweile die
hand aufhält wenn man sich ja wirklich
hinterfragen wenn so sehr auf das thema
jetzt abgezielt wird der koran als muss
ich aber trotzdem fragen wenn es richtig
gelesen habe in ihrer vita sind
dreifacher vater
und wenn sie jetzt sagen dass wir den
schul getestet wird weil die kinder sind
gar nicht anstecken also besser nicht
testen
das geht für mich nicht ganz zusammen
wir hätten sie es lieber ihre kinder
würden dass corinna mit nach haus
bringen wissen sie in den schulen ich
alles selbst wie sie schon richtig sagt
der dreifache familienvater mein
achtjähriger sohn erst wurde erzählt
dass man in den schulen dass dich das
geschultes personal nur diese tests
durchführen kann jetzt sollen die kinder
sich selbst testen
das bedeutet also die kinder sollen sich
selbst im gesicht rumfummeln und dort
irgendwelche tests durchführen
ich halte das für absolut daneben auch
teilweise rechtlich sehr problematisch
dass ungeschultes personal sich an
meinen kindern vergreift was passiert
wenn diese kinder verletzt werden was
passiert mit den seelischen und
psychischen störungen wieder einhergehen
also diese ganze impfstrategie in den
schulen und das belegen ja auch andere
länder die das eben nicht machen sind
völlig deplatziert und hier sollten sie
sich auch wirklich die eltern werden
dass das nicht um greift das hier im
prinzip auf unsere kinder mittlerweile
so ein druck ausgeübt wird und auch die
die klassifizierung in den schulen dass
kinder im prinzip ausgesondert werden
weil sie sich infiziert haben
das sind ja auch psychische schäden die
dort mit den kindern geschehen und das
sollten wir wirklich thematisieren und
deswegen sage ich auch ganz klar hände
weg von unseren kindern
okay die kinderfrage haben wir jetzt
sehr intensiv abgehandelt kann man noch
von anderen punkt und sie haben glaube
ich in diesen 99 prozent die auch mit
inkludiert der einzelhandel die
selbstständigen und so weiter alle die
müssen ja auch noch ein stück vertrauen
jetzt in politik setzen ich glaube sie
sind selber auch lange selbstständig
tätig gewesen
also insofern wo kann jetzt noch
vertrauen herkommen und was kann
opposition dazu beitragen wir weisen
darauf hin wo soll das vertrauen her
kommen ist eine berechtigte frage die
unternehmen der mittelstand hat
mittlerweile kein vertrauen in die
politik wir sehen überall die proteste
steigern sich in der bevölkerung das
vertrauen erodiert weil einfach keine
strategie erkennbar ist wir sind jetzt
angeblich in der dritten welle kommt
dann die vierte fünfte sechste welle
wir müssen einfach auch den leuten
erklären dass wir mit diesem virus leben
werden und dass der virus wird auch die
nächsten jahre wenn nicht jahrzehnte
bestehen bleiben und das müssen wir auch
deutlich machen und die unternehmen
haben alle
auch für sich selbst maßnahmen ergriffen
die auch funktionieren wir müssen ein
bisschen flexibilität auch den leuten
einhergehen und die selbstverantwortung
und die haben die menschen wir sind
keine dummen kinder dass wir uns
permanent von einer
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz und von der
kanzlerin sagen lassen müssen was wir zu
tun und zu lassen haben wir müssen
lernen mit der pandemie zu leben das war
der afc bundesvorsitzende des deutschen
bundestages kino copala hier im phoenix
tagesgespräch dankeschön nach berlin
vielen dank